[Musique]
et pour le coup de coeur qui purent
direction une autre cité royale saint
germain en laye bon sens mélanie
politesse pour ça une ville donc et
surtout une famille qui a régné sur la
france
et oui alors cette dynastie à l'araignée
de 13/100 28 à 15 189
je veux bien sûr parler des valois et de
membres de cette famille sont à
l'honneur à saint-germain-en-laye henri
ii et marguerite de valois
tous les deux sont nés dans la cité
yvelinoise qu il en rend hommage alors
pour le père henry 2 direction le
château le musée d'archéologie nationale
lui consacre une exposition à l'occasion
du 500e anniversaire de sa naissance
pour rappel henri ii est le deuxième
fils de françois 1er
il n'était pas destiné à régner mais son
frère françois décès dans quinze 136 il
devient donc dauphin pour accéder au
trône en 15 147 il sera roi du rhône
douzaine d'années écouter ce que vous
allez pouvoir découvrir dans cette
exposition personnalité dans les deux
bien sûr qu'il découvrira au travers de
nombreuses oeuvres à la fois concernant
directement henri ii est également la
production artistique sous henri deux
ans dans l'entourage du roi mais
également l'un des propos majeures de
l'exposition
et de souligner l'importance de la
présence d'henri ii ici même à saint
germain en laye qui devient durant son
règne la principale résidence du roi
dans une histoire de soi qui est assez
méconnue par rapport à celle de son père
le célèbre françois 1er aussi une
célèbre bataille marignons fameux 15
115ème est l'un des épisodes du règne
d'henri ii a donné une exposition une
expression ainsi en tête une expression
lire aussi une exposition bien d'avoir
une expression
oui c'était d'expression qui vient d'un
duel un reflet d'une féroce rivalité
entre l'entourage du roi et celui de son
père une rivalité qui va amener au
fameux duel opposant la châtaigneraie le
proche d'andy et jarnac alors le dernier
le vainqueur surprise de par un coup
surprenant dans le jarret une histoire
que l'on peut re découvrir cette
exposition qui dure donc jusqu'au 14
juillet et les valois entretien inspiré
malanje un chorégraphe
oui si je vous dit marguerite de valois
à qui pensez-vous la reine margot margot
bien sûr le célèbre roman d'alexandre
dumas publiés
1845 mais aussi le film de patrice
chéreau de cas de 1994 avec isabelle
adjani et daniel auteuil marguerite de
valois inspire alors le chorégraphe dont
vous parliez tout à l'heure grégory
c'est régis obadia sa dernière création
ce noble sobrement reine margot une
pièce d'un peu plus d'une heure et j'ai
sauvé dial a créé à la demande du
directeur du théâtre alexandre dumas qui
fête cette année ses 30 ans l'histoire
de margaux est dure et violente rappelez
vous vos cours d'histoire marguerite
épouse henri de navarre
henri iv quelques jours avant la saint
barthélémy et le chorégraphe lui a
choisi surtout de faire parler les
émotions sont nés dans la danse
contemporaine
donc c'est une narration mais c'est pas
une narration classique
donc il ya par moments je pense que les
gens vont reconnaître les personnages
par moments il un terrain il incarne un
caractère un personnage entre guillemets
et à d'autres moments
ils sont ils sont plus abstrait c'est
c'est le langage c'est la danse qui
parle alors la première de reine margot
c'est le 11 avril prochain au théâtre
alexandre dumas et c'est un menteur et
pas besoin d'attendre autant pour
retrouver mélanie poker et son émission
le 7-8 culture puisque c'est après ce
journal merci mélanie